قبل نحو 100 عام بدات نواه تشكل النظام
السياسي للحكم في تركيا بتاسيس الجمهوريه
التركيه وتعيين مصطفى كمال اتاتورك رئيسا
لها واعطي رئيس البلاد السلطات المطلقه
وكان عصمه اينون اول رئيس للوزراء
للجمهوريه وتله فتح اوكيار صدق البرلمان
في ابريل عام
1924 على الدستور الثاني الذي كان حكم
الحزب الواحد لاكثر من عقدين ونصف حكم
خلالها حزب الشعب الجمهوري الذي اسسه
اتاتورك في نظام برلماني الى ان تاسس
الحزب الديمقراطي وحكم مرات متتاليه
تعاقبت على تركيا انقلابات عسكريه
رهنت مصيره ومستقبل نظامها السياسي بدءا
من انقلاب ما يعام 1960 على الرئيس
الوزراء عدنان مندريس الذي تم اعدامه ثم
ما عرف في مدارس ادار على 71 بانقلاب
المذكره في اشاره لمذكره عسكريه للجيش
سقطت معه حكومه سليمان ديميرين فانقلاب
سبتمبر ايلول عام 80 وق رئيس هيئه اركان
الجيش التركي الجنرال كنعان افرين مع قاده
الجيش التركي الاربعه البري البحري الجوي
والدرك بدعوى حمايه المبادئ الاساسيه
للجمهوريه التركيه لينتج لاحقا عام 82
دستورا جديدا عزز دور الجيش في الحياه
المدنيه بذريعه حمايه الجمهوريه
والعلمانيه وعام 97 حدث ما يمكن وصفه
بالانقلاب الابيض بعدما اصدر مجلس الامن
القومي قرارات اطاحت بحكومه نجم الدين
اربكان وتم حل حزب الرفاه لكن منذ 2002
شكل فوز حزب العداله والتنميه في
الانتخابات التشريعيه نقطه تحول بارزه
بدات معها تحولات وتعديله متدرجه في بنيه
نظام السياسي خصوصا مع فوزه المتكرر في كل
الانتخابات التي نظمت في تلك الفتره دون
ان تخوله تنفيذ امراضه في تعديل الدستور
وشكلت محاوله انقلاب الفاشله في الخامس
عشر من يوليو عام 2016 نقطه تحول بدورها
دفعت عاما بعدها الى على تعديله دستوريه
شملت 18 تعديلا وتم اقرارها وابرز معالمها
الانتقال من النظام البرلماني الى الرئاسي
بعد ان كانت السلطه التنفيذيه ثنائيه
البنيه وتتكون من رئيس الجمهوريه ومجلس
الوزراء ورفع عدد مقاعد البرلمان الى 600
التغييرات مهدت الطريق لتنظيم انتخابات
تشريعيه كل خمس سنوات بدل اربع متزامده مع
الانتخابات الرئاسيه باقتراع شعبي عام
والغي مركز رئيس الوزراء وتركزت السلطه
التنفيذيه في منصب الرئيس الذي كان رمزيا
ويتم اختيار الوزراء من قبله يعتبر حزب
العداله والتنميه التعديلات جزءا من خطه
للاصلاح دستوري والقانونيه التي بداها
الحزب منذ 2002 لمجابهه تحديات امنيه
وسياسيه وتفادي الحكومات الائتلافيه الهشه
ويرى اردوغان انها تعديله لم تستطع بعد
استئصال ما سماها الروح الانقلابيه التي
اعتمد على اساسها دستور عام 82 فبين عام
61 القرن الماضي وحتى 2002 شكلت اكثر من
33 حكومه لم يبقى اكثرها صمودا في السلطه
18 شهرا فقط في المقابل يرى معرض اردوغان
ان الانتقال للنظام الرئاسي خطوه تزيد
الاستبداد تحت مسميات ديمقراطيه ولهذا جاء
اتفاق سته احزاب معارضه على العوده للنظام
البرلماني او مسمته النظام البرلماني
المعزز في كل الاحوال تعبر تركيا
الجمهوريه نحو مئويتها الثانيه في ظل جدل
واسع بشئ لنظام الحكم وشكله